قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني في سوناك ان
الشراكه البريطانيه القطريه قويه ومتنوعه
في عده مجالات واضاف سوناك خلال استقباله
اميره دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد الفاني
في لندن ان اللقاء كان فرصه لمناقشه
الشراكه الاقتصاديه بين البلدين
من جانبه قال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن
حمد الساني ان العلاقات القطريه
البريطانيه متينه للغايه وان تبادل
التجاري بين البلدين يشهد ارتفاعا سنويا
مطاردا
[موسيقى]
هذا العام سيعقد الحوار الاستراتيجي بين
بلدينا وسيناقش عده مواضيع مع رئيس
الحكومه الامن وامن المنطقه وكذلك تعزيز
شراكاتنا الاقتصاديه التبادل التجاري بين
بلدينا بلغ العام المنصرم نحو 13 مليار
و500 مليون جنيه استرليني ويشهد سنويا
ارتفاعا مضطردا اذ لدينا استثمارات كثيره
هنا